last time you might recall with ms ladi
you were solving equations what's
equation again can someone hand up give
me a description of what an equation is
y Adam now let's just pause that for a
second this you might may or may not
remember if you haven't you know i would
suggest right now this is not an
equation yet it almost is something else
it starts of an in yeah kimi o your
statements that it's true a bright side
very ah ok so we're going to get to the
credit innocentive this what what Aiden
suggesting is something else what is
this this is called an expression it
says something and it says it with
numbers there isn't any algebra yet
because what I've got here I'll know
what all these numbers are algebra is
when we introduce those things called
perennials remember those it's where we
label something where there's a number
and I don't don't want to use I know I
know what seven is Noah for is I don't
know what five is order of operations
told me to do the multiplication first
so seven times for of course is 28 28
plus five is ok so now now I have an
equation ok now what did I add that made
it an equation it was an English side
thank you and this is what can we
suggested right well you've got two
themes there's a tear to science there
are two sides and they're equal to one
another in fact the equal sign if you
have a close look at the equal sign just
like the division sign the equal sign
tells you what it is it's two things
that are exactly the same just like
division is where you've got something
that's been separated out and shared two
different people tada sir the equal sign
a fat magic the equal sign having a
mathematical sentence where you say
something and something else are exactly
equal to each other is what makes it an
equation right same base where that word
is coming from okay now I said before
these are all numbers right so that's
what I would call a numerical expression
over here a numerical equation all up
but if I want to introduce some algebra
are you going unfortunately yes I've got
another one
I was spying on us clearly they yeah so
you seven let's give him something we're
watching this shall we okay now where
were we said it's an expression well
it's an equation but I know what all
these things are right so that's why
it's give know America yeah what would
make this what could make this algebraic
what would be Albert yeah yeah okay if I
have some terms in here which may be
like a lion is something I don't know we
took this equation this is a numerical
equation and I added in something that I
didn't know i added a label for
something and i wasn't sure what it was
you killed stretching your question its
own questions like I know that what
you're okay for the sake of time I'm
gonna ask you to pause on that and hold
that door okay we'll get better okay now
importantly you saw last time because
you knew what substitution was if you
saw something like this you can
substitute numbers for that letter and
you could try to find out what the
letter was not ask you for questions
right now do you remember what that
method was called he's already gave it a
name it starts with the jeep and to see
a few words it yes yeah guess it jack
right so i could try out why well maybe
why is to me why is fine even why is a
half or negative one the last iteration
joking but we saw we experienced that
was not a very efficient way of doing
things was it why not why wasn't it very
efficient your day yeah sometimes you
have to guess guess guess and it's just
tiring so instead and that's right like
what you get non sir it's like also what
like I just got a chance really so run
solving equations by trial and error yes
in check we're going to use bloody the
candy
here's to remember if what you have is
two things that are equal to each other
two things at exactly balance then if
they're the same you can do things to
both sides and it stays balanced so for
example if you haven't already would you
write down this algebraic equation and
we are going to solve it with logic okay
so the first thing I'm going to do is
remember we said seven times for we knew
what that was right what is sometimes
you put it very good so i'm going to
write that on my next line and i
especially want to emphasize to you that
these two lines are parallel to each
other right sup I've written it down the
page not across the page because these
are kind of like parallel lines of
working okay now remembering that I'm
saying this thing and this B are the
same they are equal if I do something to
one side then I should do to the other
side so for example I had some objects
on these two sides of the scale if I
took something off one side and I want
to keep the balance I'd better take it
off the other yeah so here's what I'm
gonna do okay I want to get to what I
will find out what this pretty rule is
and I don't want to just guess so i want
to subtract something from both sides
that makes that a little easier to see
what can i subtract from both sides i
used to get its Rick oh ok ok what kind
of time for the weight on the way I give
it 4 not yet not yet I want us to solve
together and then maybe we'll have time
to discuss some other solutions can I
get a suggestion you can- funny
i could subtract 48 for both sides I'll
be great in fact on the next line that's
all right there okay this is what's
already there 28 plus 5 way and there's
already a 33 but I've left of space so
that if you have another color to be the
likely it's in a different color i'm
going to subtract 28 from this side
which means i have to subtract 28 from
this side okay i'm keeping everything
balanced otherwise thinks get a topic we
subtracted 28 perfect eyes my question
because why what is it what does it do
on the left-hand side what happens when
I've got 28 take away 28 that's just
your not tell me that's zero right so
all that's left over here is 5 lots of
wine that was less in sight yes why
retweets one okay so you've already gone
a few extra steps I want to go through
slowly I don't want you guys to jump to
the solution a lot of you guys are
jumping to the solution and I want to
see how you got me on the right hand
side game i need the working right 33
taking a 28 it's just fine now again
this is a balance thing right both sides
of the same so I want to do something to
both sides that would give me just one
by itself what am I gonna do oh yeah
vanish okay now subtractions a great
idea subtraction worked last time it got
rid of this 28 business okay but
unfortunately subtractions not going to
work for us this time why isn't it
what's the operation between five and
why that's actually implied oh yeah very
good so when we write five white
remember when we work this abbreviation
it's five times like the reason why
subtracting he worked is because you
added 28 so I can undo that over here
I'm going to do it like this you run
that for me see that what's happening
over here the left this is fractions
we've been dealing with this for weeks
right what happens you can cancel here
right cancel cancel leaving you with
just wine and on the right hand side 5/5
cancel again it's one and there's our
answer ok now that took a bit of time to
but this is much more logical it was
thoughtful wasn't just random it was
logical